hello
stratford haven district council is
consulting on its site allocations plan
its preferred options stage whenever we
consult on a plan we like to do a
presentation
for parish councils um obviously because
of kovid19 we can't do that
this year um we have done a
series of summary videos to help explain
what the um
what site allocations plan is about
instead but
i thought it would be useful if i ran
through the presentation i would have
given
if we'd all be able to uh to meet up and
hopefully i can
go through in a bit more detail about
what the the site allocations
uh is about um i'm gonna do it in two
parts this is the first part
um and we're gonna focus on chapters two
and three of the plan
to relate to reserve housing sites and
self-built sites
um this is uh live i haven't got a
script so we
will see how i and we get on um
so hopefully uh it will be useful um
perhaps the sort of 20 20 minutes um
see how we go and let's hope the the
technology works
right saying that
it's not working there we go
right click on the right screen so
always a good start isn't it
so uh this is the contents of the
slideshow locations plan
it's uh arranged over eight chapters got
four appendices and four annexes
um it's the same structure and uh
the content is similar to
last year's proposed submission version
just to be absolutely clear that
proposed submission version
has been formally withdrawn has no
status
so this preferred options version which
is a slight step backwards
if you like in the process but this
preferred options version does replace
that proposed submission version
and just to draw your attention to the
fact that the policy
references that's the sap references
or the site specific site references
proposal numbers and references uh may
you have
changed so uh please do make sure you're
using
current 2020 references
and not last year's um
just to recap so there are a number of
uh components to the sci-fi allocations
plan
um planning we use a lot of acronyms
i'll try to avoid using acronyms um but
i may slip into it uh so i apologize if
that happens
um obviously the main one is the saab
which is site allocation
plan um i much refer it to a site
allocation
document much more cheerful having a
plan
um so the the sap saturn locations plan
has got a number of components to it and
i'll run through those
as we go through uh this part of the
presentation said earlier
is focusing on chapters two and three
which is reserve housing sites which
in many respects is the bulk plan and
the self-built sites
and then part two will cover chapters
four
through seven um chapter eight
is has got all the maps for the um for
all the chapters in it
the contents of the sap um it covers
things that are not covered
in the core strategy itself so of course
strategy
is our existing development plan
document we adopted that in 2016
that runs to 2031. um
there are a number of things we said we
would defer to the site allocations plan
and that's exactly what we're doing
okay let's see if hopefully it works oh
there we go it does work
so in terms of timetable
uh we're consulting at the moment
through to 18th of december
and we'll then take on board the
comments received we'll then
prepare the next version of the plan and
this will be the proposed submission
version
and hopefully we should read that in
april and
again consult on that for six weeks
in the spring
we'll then take that version any
comments received any changes to the
plan
and formally submit that to the
government
for independent examination
so because this is a development plan
document
it's a part of the statutory the legal
plan for the district
we have to have it examined by
independent sorry
independent planning specter appointed
by the government
and they check that we've prepared the
plan properly
and the plan is essentially fit for
purpose or sound it's the uh
the banning jargon on that one so there
will then be a examination public
chaired by the inspector
um hopefully if all goes well we'll then
have a
positive report and we're about to adopt
uh
following summer it might be further
consultation if we need to make further
changes
so hopefully not
obviously if we can do that timetable
quicker we will
certainly endeavor to do so but that's a
realistic
uh timetable to to go through those
various uh
stages so we're we're currently
preferred options
we'll then move back to propose
submission
when there'll be another round of
consultation and then submit it to the
uh
the government and then the importance
of the weight
we can give to the emerging plan
increases as we go through the
through the stages effectively
okay so it's just some plan making
context
um as i've said the satellite
allocations plan
will sit alongside the existing core
strategy
it'll run to 2031. it also sits
alongside those made neighborhood plans
we have in the district
um it's very much
an interim measure a sort of short-term
stop gap measure
before we move to uh the full review of
the core strategy which we're looking to
start
in earnest uh next year um
you may have picked up that we're
looking to do that review
with our colleagues in warwick district
so a new plan for
the whole of south warwickshire for
stratford and warwick districts
and that that will be the reveal that
will extend we'll create a new plan
period
uh let's say perhaps even up to 2050
um and it'll be that plan that we can
incorporate a whole raft of new policy
objectives whether it's climate change
uh biodiversity um more employment space
and so forth
um or new approaches to infrastructure
but that that's very much for the the
new plan
the site allocations plan is very much
it's it's just adding a bit more detail
to the approach
already in the core strategy so we can't
change the fundamentals
what we're trying to do is work within
parameters set by the course strategy
to give a uh cover a few extra topics
that say we didn't for various reasons
cover off in the um the course strategy
itself
i think it's important having said that
though that just to
think about the wider context and uh
primarily i'm referring to the
government's
recent consultation on planning reforms
and planning white paper
that was published over the summer
in that consultation the government
proposed a new methodology
for calculating housing needs and the
figures for stratford were
um were very high um
just to put that into context so the
current or strategy figures the
figure of 14 600 or seven hundred thirty
twelve innings per annum over that
twenty year period
that's that's calculated based on an
approach called objectively assessed
needs
since the course strategy was adopted
finished
um the government introduced something
called their standard method
and the current standard methods um
would result in a figure about 603
dwellings per annum so
a slight decrease for stratfor district
however
the the latest um government thinking is
suggesting that
uh is proposing a new standard method
and if that if that standard method is
revised as proposed it would lead to a
significant increase in
in housing for the district uh
increasing to
one six some five homes per annum
now if that happens then
we don't yet know if that's going to
happen or um
if the government going to change their
their approach um or what transitional
arrangements they're going to put in
place but clearly moving from what would
be a
a lay figure in that complex although
730 is is still
relatively challenging moving from 79 30
to 200 to 1675 per annum
uh it will be difficult but the benefit
having the site allocations plan
is we'll have a a rafter reserve site so
i'll come onto these in the moment
that will enable us to uh smooth out
that transition
have an effective transition to maintain
housing supply
so if if the planning context changes
the site allocations plan will have a
really important role
to help manage the transition from the
current system
to the new planning system um
just to reiterate and say because it's
on the screen
um the the figures in the course
strategy the 730 figure per annum
that's the base need it's a minimum
figure
and on top of that the uh the inspector
in the examine the course strategy
does did require us to add on a further
20
um reserve figure so that's a further
2920 homes on top of the 14 600
already in the plan and that's as i said
one of the key things that the
site allocations plan is seeking to do
is to plan
for that reserve
so just to recap whilst we're what's the
um
starting locations plan has specific uh
purposes and reasons for doing it
changing context could mean it has a
very useful
role um anyway so it's really important
that although it's a short-term measure
that we get the cycle locations plan
done and dusted
as quickly as we can
so if we move to essentially chapter 2
which is reserve housing sites
um say
last last year we had the proposed
submission version
um and in that version 2019 we
we we had identified southern college as
a constraint to
significant development that essentially
meant that we excluded
a whole area of the district on the in
the east the district
and having to provide reserve housing
sites
because of the capacity at southern
college um
further work has established that that
actually is not an issue and that
further capacity can be accommodated at
college and therefore it's no longer
constraint to development
so we are able to identify reserve sites
right across the district
and that's what the plan does
it also enables us to exclude the green
belt
again and also exclude the cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty
so those parts of the district within
those designations
will not have reserve sites identified
in
um we're also still proposing to make
like the political choice of uh not
identifying reserve housing sites in
those settlements
that have got reserve housing sites
identified through their neighborhood
development plan
so that's a political choice we're still
proposing to do that
i'll come back to the relationship with
neighbor plans in a moment
and it's also just worth bearing out and
interesting the point that so the
numbers in the course strategy so
policy six cs16 um those numbers listed
there
they exclude any reserve size they just
deal with the
14 600 figure so the numbers in the site
applications plan
they are on top of what's already in the
core strategy
in the same way as of course strategy
sites were identified which was
a bottom-up suitability approach we're
doing the same thing
with the site allocations plan size
what that does mean is that the
the spread the distribution of reserve
sites across the district
is not even okay what we haven't done
is apply a mathematical exercise
to the the settlement hierarchy
distribution the course strategy
to match uh the percentage uh that's in
the course strategy with the percentage
of reserve sites
we've not done that because we believe
it's right you start with
the suitability of the sites themselves
rather than arbitrary number
and then try and see if you've got sites
match the arbitrary number
so it's say it's it's not a mathematical
exercise what we've
applied we have taken into account
the hierarchy of the distribution the
different categories of settlements so
the main town the main world centres the
different categories of local service
village and i'll come onto that in a
minute
um but say the rationale for the
identifying specific science is based on
their individual
suitability it does give a very uneven
distribution of reserve sites
um we've also tried to reflect
um site densities uh
in sort of to reflect the the
distribution of
um development in the course strategy in
cs15
so the different hierarchy of
settlements um
their different sustainability criteria
we've tweaked the density of the reserve
sites to reflect that so
in stratford town for example that the
density is slightly higher
and the local service village is four
for example
the the density is slightly lower and
again that's to reflect the
relative sustainability of those
settlements
okay so in terms of identifying the
reserve sites themselves
as i said a bottom-up approach uh we've
used our technical evidence
to inform which sites we're going with
or proposing to go with
uh the main study is the strategic
housing land availability assessment or
schla
and that looks of the suitability
availability and
achievability of development of science
so it's
all about identifying which sites we
think are
deliverable for development
there's no point in identifying a site
when it's either not suitable or
can't be delivered we've then
refined that process using flood risk
assessments
um impact assessments and that's been a
mammoth
piece of work uh a new piece of work
that we've done this time
uh highway assessments and again
infrastructure capacity assessments
including education so all that
technical evidence
is underpinning and explains why we've
chosen the sites
we have it's all on the website which is
www.stratfor.gov dot uk
or slash sapo which is s-a-p-p-o
and that will take you straight there
and there will be links to the
technical work um technical studies that
you can
look through to help understand so why
why we've identified the reserve
sites uh also worth saying that
we've for each of the reserve sites
we've made a site pro forma
and then they're listed in examinex ii
the plan itself
and it just identifies some of the
specific
constraints and considerations that need
to be taken into account
if those sites were to come forward
uh okay so this is a map of the district
and the
green lobs um they identified
assessments which have got reserved
sites identified in them
and then if you can possibly see
some of the blobs um both green yellow
have got a sort of bluey grey um
outline circle to them they identify
settlements where there is a
self-built site proposed
okay
right uh in terms of neighbour
development plans
um again we want to give uh
precedence to them communities have put
in an awful amount of hard work to
to bring them forward we want to show
our support and commitment for them
so where a neighbour plan identifies a
built-up area boundary which
are covering presentation 2 or a reserve
site then we'll give um
we will say we won't uh
we we won't do it through the site
allocations plan the neighborhood plan
does it adequately
we will uh we won't seek to redo it
if you like um now for that to work
um we have to um
have a draw a line have a threshold and
say okay at this point
um we will accept that neighbor pan um
is um has been is at a stage where
um it's not going to change and we can
give
give certainty to that
so it's either a neighbor plan that's
been made or what we've said is
significantly advanced so that is
where stratfor district council has
agreed to send
the neighbor plan to referendum so if
the neighbour plan hasn't reached that
stage yet
then we haven't taken it into account
and there are a number of plans that are
currently coming through the process the
company maybe even at examination
that say we haven't taken the fact that
they might have reserved
sites or built up area boundaries in
their plan into account because they're
not
significantly advanced by any definition
what it does mean is that as our plan
our societal locations plan moves
forward
into the next stage and those plans also
progress
we will need to update and amend the
cycle locations plan
to reflect the um the changing status
of the neighbor plan
let's say for us to fully take it into
account it needs to be significantly
advanced and not subject to change and
that is
the point of which it goes to a
referendum that's the definition we're
using
so that is why just to reiterate
there'll be some plans
some navy plans in the process
that have got reserve sites in them have
got built-up area boundaries
but we haven't taken into account as yet
so we will do in due course
um just to reiterate as well that there
has been some
conservation that the sap is
an accusation that the sap is riding
roughshod over
uh neighbour plans and wishes of the
community well that's not the case
um yeah just because a
uh site allocations plan identifies as a
reserve
site in a in a neighborhood plan then
that doesn't undermine the neighborhood
plan
everything else about the neighbor plan
remains valid
um it's the same relationship between um
the local plan and the the national
planning policy
framework you know if if the local plan
is silent on the issue then the mppf
takes precedence equally for if an ndp
is silent on
issue of reserve sites then the site
allocations plan will take precedence
so it's also worth remembering that when
the government introduced localism
that they always intended that neighbor
plans would sit alongside
local plans such as the psychiatrist
strategy
there was never an intention that a
neighbourhood plan would be the sole
plan
for an area so the fact that
you've got part of the planning
framework being set by a neighbor plan
and part of the planning framework being
set by the site allocations plan
that's perfectly acceptable and that's
actually the way the system should work
that that shows the system is working
properly because
the the local plan the site on the cases
plan is
is dealing with strategic bigger or
wider than parish issues whereas
the neighbor plan is dealing with
very localized issues so it's quite
proper
the two documents three if include the
core strategy
work together to provide the context for
and planning applications in the area
now there are a number of neighbour
plans that have identified reserve sites
and i
thank those communities for grasping the
nettle
or reserve sites and they're listed
there on screen
and what the site allocations plan does
do i mean this is positive reference
sap2
is just try and ensure consistent
approach to the release
of reserve sites so that um
it doesn't matter if it if the site was
identified through a neighborhood plan
or through the site allocations plan
the manner of their release is
consistent
and that will give clarity and
consistency to uh the approach and
clarity to
uh residents and local communities as
well as the landowners and developers to
know
where that where their site sits in that
in that wider context so
it's up to is an important one it just
um
[Music]
doesn't provide a consistency to the
reserve sites
identified through neighboring plans and
obviously sap2 will need to be updated
if other ndps come forward
with additional reserve sites through
them as well
excuse me
right so um i've just noticed time we
i said about 20 minutes i think i've
probably been coming for that
that long anyway let's crack on
um reserve sites having
identified a pool of play circa 3000
homes
on reserve sites um we need to establish
a
consistent and reasonable way of
releasing those reserve sites
and there are four reasons or for
purposes why we've identified reserve
sites
the first person is to help us maintain
a five-year housing land supply
uh purpose b is
to provide additional housing should the
hundred hectares of employment land
uh gay tonight underneath come forward
purpose c
is to meet uh any uh or contribute to
meeting any shortfall
in housing arising from outside the
district but within coventry and
warwickshire
and purpose d is to contribute to
a shortfall housing arising outside the
district elsewhere
so those four purposes have been set
through the
court strategy and we're not revisiting
them
what the site allocations plan is doing
is setting out how we would deal with
those
um purposes so
we've massage allocations plan is
setting some triggers so
for five years housing land supply
um what we're proposing is to set a
trigger 5.5
years now you might may well ask why is
it not
five years well the reason is the way
the
the national planning policy framework
is written as soon as you lose
five-year supply your
relevant policies relating to housing
supply ceased to be up to date so
if we left it to five years and and now
um our our supply fell below five then
all the good work we're doing that
through the site allocations plan
wouldn't actually really have any
any weight any any relevance because
we've lost the power to apply it
apply those policies so we need to put
the threshold
above five and we think 5.5 is
the right figure so that means that
uh before we get to five if it comes
if it gets to 5.4 we can enact our
and reserve size and that will then
bring those forward
and that'll then ensure that we maintain
um
we're always above five at all points so
that's why the trigger has to be
five point five but it doesn't have to
be five point five it has to be above
five it
say it could it could be any any figure
we think
5.5 is the right figure and
certainly um i wouldn't want to go any
uh below that figure
because i say you want your narrowing um
your room for maneuver so if your
if your supply does drop at least you've
got the equipment half a year supply
in order to give you a bit of buffer and
remedy the
situation and the hdt
is the housing delivery test
this is a relatively new test the
government
apply it's certainly a post states the
course strategy
and it's a retrospective look on your
supply
so whereas five year supply is a forward
look hdt is a retrospective look over
the past
three years uh currently we've
uh with about 271 percent so we're doing
really well
um that's we we think
again a it's another use useful measure
uh to help us manage the supply position
and it it could help us flag up um if
if our supply is going in the wrong
direction so that's why we think it's
important to
to bring in the hd teaser as an
additional trigger
on the 100 hectares of employment land
we think a suitable trigger is the
completion of the employment buildings
there isn't a direct relationship
between jobs and housing but there's a
strong one
and we think having the buildings
complete
would then be a sufficient trigger to
then
crack open reserve sites and ensure that
we're building additional homes for
those additional jobs
wouldn't want to do any sooner because
of the perhaps the uncertainty
about whether those buildings were then
actually
developed but we think doing it at the
point of completion buildings
will then greater certainty that they'll
then be occupied and new jobs are
created
um in respect of the shortfalls from
outside the district so perhaps it's c
d um the trigger there will be through
the joint monitoring through the various
um
uh work we do here joining authorities
and uh
a statement of common ground confirming
that there is
a shortfall and b that
stratfor district is appropriate for us
to contribute
to that shortfall i think contribute to
is the key word there is not
the role of stratfor district to remedy
that shortfall
in its entirety um but simply to
contribute to it
and then uh we're proposing that
cabinet will um confirm that any of the
purpose has been triggered
be the scale of any release and then
the deliverability of those specific
sites and the release of the
reserve sites so that's the mechanism
we're proposing to
help us manage releasing reserve science
okay
now as i said earlier we've
tried to reflect the um
the distribution in the core strategies
strategy say policy cs15 which
identifies
um stratford upon ivan is the main town
you've then got the eight main rule
centers
and then you've got the the four
categories of local service village
so that's that's been the starting point
for our reserve sites and what we are
saying
is that we will release reserve sites in
that order
so we will start with uh sites in uh
stratfor by navin
if we need to release any we'll release
those when they're used up and if we
still need to release them all then move
to
the manual sensors um get slightly
complicated
um in respect of the um the main royal
centers
um and and it goes back to the way the
reserve sites have been
identified and so it's not an even
um so to we're proposing um sort of four
tranches
under the manual sentence and we'd work
through them in in sequence
so um um
acknowledging the what the mppf says
about the the value of smaller science
to housing supply we're going to
start with reserves in the smaller
reserve sites
on sites of less than 100 homes
would then move to reserve sites
identified in those neighborhood plans
so i think that the uh some wells born
in ships in uh
comington um and then would move to
um the larger reserve sites 100 to 200
homes
or the size of 200 homes plus now
because of the
um the unevenness if you like of the
distribution
what we are proposing is to pivot
um this depending on where those sites
are so
um and depending on the purpose as well
so let's let's just run through that
again
so
quite a bit of context for this so
there's firstly there are no indicative
numbers for the main rural centers as
there are
local service villages that's the way to
make the second point
is that um the total quantum for manual
centers is 1400 homes
you can't we don't think it's right to
release 1400 home
in one go so that's why we do want to
break it down
into these different branches
the challenge we've got
is that um the all the sites
that fall under uh trance c
which is a little uh medium-sized sites
100 to 200 homes
are in um in one part of the district
and all the sites that the larger sites
are in the 200 homes plus
are in another part of the district
and those parts don't really correspond
to the four
purposes so what we're proposing is
to um tweak the release of the charges
depending on the purpose
so for purpose a the five year supply
we would release them in this order so
charge a b
c c one which is uh sites of a hundred
to two hundred ames
and then c two which would be size of
two hundred homes plus
and that's the same approach
if we were to um release sites for
purpose d
as well just um beyond the commentary
and watch your housing market area
so tranche first then translate then
trans c1
and then chance c2 however
for purposes b and c
we will tweak the order of release
so we start with charge a and then b and
then we'll release
sites c2 before we do c1
and that's the same for c as well the
reason we're doing that
is because the larger sites the 200 plus
science
are all in the east of the district
whereas the 100 to 200 homes
are in the west of the district
now purposes b and c relate to
factors that originate from the east of
the district
and it seems slightly perverse if the
origin if the source of a need
is in the eastern district to then be
identifying reserve sites
in the west district in the first
instance
so in a nutshell that's why we're
tweaking the
order in which we're releasing reserve
sites it's to reflect the fact that
or to try and put the homes closer to
the
the origin or the source of the need
hopefully that makes sense um say it's
slightly complicated
but say it stems from the fact we don't
think it's appropriate to have a single
tranche of 1400 homes to release in one
go
we need to break that down somehow um
best way we thought we could do that is
to reflect the size of the sites
and then acknowledge the fact that there
was this um this distinction
between um where some of the larger
sites were between the west and east the
district
and that reflected the four purposes so
so for two of those purposes we are
tweaking we are
tweaking the uh the order in which we
are releasing
a better reflect and where the
where the source of those um those homes
comes from
so it is complicated but hopefully that
does explain it
so if you do have any questions about it
please do contact the
policy team uh email address is
planning.policy at stratford hyphen
dc.gov dot uk
that's planning dot policy
the plan itself there is some
explanatory text uh
accompanying the policies which um
explain it as well so
hopefully my attempt and explanation
here
and the explanation in the in the plan
itself
uh you'll be able to understand our
approach
okay so reserve uh
reserve sites in the local service
villages
so if you recall we've already gone
through tiers one
and two so tier one was stratfor
depending on town
tier two was the main centers so we're
now at tier three
and again we uh so three four five uh
six and seven
so again we we want to reflect the
categorization in
cs15 the
the change here is
uh to acknowledge those local service
villages
that have significantly exceeded the
indicative numbers in the course
strategy so that's
where they've exceeded by over 20
percent what we want to do
is just pull them out to their category
and put them at the bottom
so if what that means so let's say
you've got a
a category one local service village
you've already significantly provided
your numbers
um rather than being in tier three
you'll be
into tier seven so it's not saying
uh that you won't have any reserve sites
but rather they will just come at the
very end of the process
um rather than uh nearer the top so it's
trying to
acknowledge the fact that some villages
have over provided where somehow
some other sorry some others haven't
um so hopefully that's clear we're going
through the process we go through the
tears
these ones twos threes fours and then
all those lsv's that are
significantly overprovided within each
of those tiers
as with the mrcs there are certain
tranches
and those chances are based on whether
there are any
um reserve sites that were identified in
neighborhood plans
and also just to distinguish between
those
and lsvs that have not met their numbers
at all
and those that have met their numbers
um even though they're perhaps not
significantly over
over provided so yeah a breakdown and
again
we would release uh reserve sites in
that order through the tiers through the
tranches
so the lower you are down the list
the later and absolute less likely you
are to
see the reserve sites released
okay
so purpose d um relates
to if you're going to recall relates to
housing needs
a chill for housing arising from outside
couple of
and birmingham is the main um
source of that um we do fall within the
birmingham greater birmingham housing
market area
we're one of 14 authorities in that
housing market area
um when the the birmingham city plan was
adopted it was adopted before knowledge
that there was a short for about 38 000
homes
and the 14 authorities have been working
hard to address that shortfall
and we've recently published a position
statement it does confirm there is a
shortfall of
circa 2500 homes
remaining what we're doing in stratford
is proposing um to contribute
approximately
uh ninth of that shortfall
and that takes into account of the 14
authorities
and birmingham city and the black
country authorities can't
accommodate further development so if
it's left to the remaining authorities
to
to meet that um short for say two and a
half thousand homes
um that approach does need to be
confirmed through the formal duty to
cooperate
so say we're looking to be proactive and
uh
set out our approach um
i'll come on to a couple of sites we're
proposing to release in a moment
but we we think it's right that stratfor
does its bit
because we the district does fall within
the housing market
area and the housing needs um do exist
now
until 2031. um
the the um position statement
is available on our website that's
stratford.gov wk forward slash
strategic planning um i think it's
important to note that
um we are only talking about needs to
2031.
um any needs and chill course which
there there are
they do exist post 2031. uh we will pick
those up
and deal with that issue through the
review of the course strategy through
the shelf watcher plan
but the site allocations plan is solely
that these exist
to 2031.
right now i've just spent some time
going through a release mechanism
uh where i said we would start with
stratfor upon avon town sites and stuff
united town
and then go through the mineral centers
the local service villages
there's always a rule and this is it so
excuse me um
we are proposing to identify or release
uh site east of ships and road in
stratford
um to contribute to the needs of them
there's another titan structure we're
not proposing to release because we
say we don't need uh needing in terms of
numbers for our
conscience size of our contribution
we've chosen this one
uh rather than the other site
on the um eastern road um
because this one has a relationship
to a proposal site sua
5 which is the area of white land within
that black boundary
um which also relates to the core
strategy
um canal quarter regeneration zone
so this this has a wider strategic
benefit to help us deliver
our existing policy aims of regeneration
in canal quarter
and then um bringing four digital or
replacement employment land for that to
happen so
that's why we think this is the right
site in stratfor to release
because of those wider policy objectives
um now map of green which is a
category 4 local service village and
this would ordinarily be at the bottom
of the
pile and tier 6 however
because of where map of green is in
relation to redditch and
on the right hand map the that last
wave of the housing on the left is is
redditch
we think it's appropriate to bring
forward
these sites um sooner or later
outside of the release mechanism that
we've just talked about
the the rationale for that is that the
um the left hand
boundary of the site so a b and c
the left the black line there the
left-hand line
um is the is the borough boundary of
reddish the district boundary with
redditch
the area of land uh that's why it's
immediately
left of uh parcels b and c
between them and the road and that
housing
is identified in the redditch by our
local plan
for housing so that land immediately
to the left is going to come forward and
be built on
because of that we think it makes sense
to think about the sites comprehensively
um and provide additional housing these
these sites here would would be accessed
through
uh the new site in register they
wouldn't access onto the
um the 435 which is the road on the
right
they'd come through redditch and we
think by doing a comprehensive approach
to
development you can have a better
solution in terms of the open space
maintaining that sense of separation
so that's why we're proposing uh sites
and map of the green
because say redditch uh borough is fully
within
the birmingham housing market these
sites are on the edge of
um edge of redditch they're not in the
green belt the greenbelt boundaries
so their non-green belt boundaries very
close to
the reddish we think again they're close
to the source of the need
the better science to release and rather
than say more sites in stratford
or in in one of the main or centres
which will be some distance
from birmingham so that's that's what
we're proposing in respect of
birmingham circa 265 homes uh
stratford's contribution to that short
form
right um last bit of this first part of
the presentation
uh custom build and self-built housing
sites
so we have a legal requirement to
maintain and register of those
individuals who are
keen to have their own grant design
we have a registered i think there's
over 150 people on it at the moment
we are proposing a policy which is sap
six
um to identify uh set out our approach
to
uh meeting these needs and we we didn't
do in the course strategy because the
legal requirement to meet the needs of
shelf builders
only emerged post core strategy
so that's why we're covering it off in
the site allocations plan
so there's sort of three three
approaches to it
first is we're looking to provide some
self-build plots
on um customer plots on the two new
settlements at gage and i'm thief and
long-lasting airfield
the second is to deal with or to set out
the approach of dealing with
uh unallocated um if you like windfall
applications for self-build plots
um that we get on on allocated sites
and then uh the meat of the policy is to
identify 11 um allocated sites that we
will
uh release uh for self-build custom
build needs
directly now all those all those um
those three approaches they need to have
uh legal access to highway utility
collections and also be
low carbon um so
also the um so if you want to find out
more about the self build register
you can do so on that web link which is
stratfor dot dot dot uk forward slash
self build
in terms of the allocated sites the 11
they're listed there
so these would be released for uh
self-built there'll be a
legal obligation to ensure their plots
are made available for self and customer
builders and as opposed to general
market needs
some of those sites featured in the say
last year's proposed submission version
um some of the sites i think the name
has changed slightly to better
or more accurately reflect where they
are and then we've got some
new ones there as well um all these
sites the landowners have expressed in
an interest uh to bring them forward and
self-build custom build sites
because again there's no point uh trying
to bring forth science the owner
doesn't want to deliver in this type of
development but the owners are
supportive of
uh self-built customer build coming
forward on these sites
so through the schla we've assessed them
and we consider them to be
suitable sites as well for development
okay so um
just to recap in terms of all the
consultation documents you're on the
website stratfor.gov dot uk forward
slash
sapo you can respond uh by the
interactive document
uh via that web page or you can sub
comments to policy.consultation at
stratfordhypenbc.gov dot uk
and if you do have any queries uh please
do email
planning.policy stratfor type in dc.gov
dot uk
there are a number of um short summary
videos on the website as well
there's also a summary leaflet and
we've also prepared some maps of
settlements uh showing all the site
proposals in one place
so you'll be able to zoom in find where
you live and then see which
proposals directly affect uh you as well
that's
uh more helpful as well uh thank you for
listening
um so this is the uh part one of the
presentation
and uh part two will cover the the other
aspects
of the site allocations plan but hope
you found it useful
and uh so yeah please do keep safe and
well
see you again soon